When the user opens Wittr, we want
to start by showing the latest post
the device received,
before going to the network.
Then we make the web socket connection,
and
we start receiving new posts one by one.
When we receive these posts,
we want to display them of course.
But also, we want to add them to the set
of posts we already have stored.
We also want to remove entries that
are too old to be worth keeping.
A database is the best model for this.
It means we can add and
remove individual posts as needed,
iterate over them, and query the data.
The web platform has
a database called index DB and
it's fair to say it has a bit
of a bad reputation, but
hopefully we can break
through that in this chapter.
And we're not going to touch
our service workers' script for
a bit, we're going to concentrate on
learning IDB sharpen how it ticks.
Then we'll integrate it into
a whole offline first experience.
If you've used NoSQL databases before,
IDB will seem familiar.
If you've only used relational databases
before, this might seem a little weird.
But if you've never used databases
before, well, that might even help.
As you can come to index DB fresh,
without trying to translate it to
similar but ultimately different
things you've encountered.
First up,
here's the shape of indexedDB Databases.
With IndexedDB,
you can have multiple databases
with whatever name you give them.
But we're only going to be creating one.
Generally you'll only have
one database per app.
That database contains multiple
objects stores, generally one for
each kind of thing you want to store.
An object store contains
multiple values.
These can be JavaScript objects,
strings, numbers, dates, or arrays.
Items in the object's store can
have a separate primary key or
you can assign a property of
the values to be the key.
The key must be unique
within an object store.
It becomes the way to
identify a particular object.
Later you can get, set, add,
remove, iterate over items in object
stores as part of a transaction.
All read or write operations in
IndexDB must be part of a transaction.
This means that if you
create a transaction for
a series of steps and one of the actions
fail, none of them are applied.
The state of the database would be
as if none of the steps happened.
You can also create indexes within an
object store, which provides a different
view of the same data ordered
by particular properties.
The model here is similar to a lot of
databases which makes a lot of sense.
The browser support is good as well
with every major browser supporting it.
So why does IndexDB have
such a bad reputation?
Unfortunately the API
is a little horrid, and
often creates spaghetti code.
It's all asynchronous which is fine,
but it predates promises.
So it kind of invented its own
event-based promise system
which creates really confusing code.
Now, I'm a true believer in teaching the
web platform rather than libraries, but
IDBs APIs is so clumsy,
I'm going to chicken out of doing that.
We're going to use IndexDB Promised.
This is a really small library
that mirrors the IndexDB API but
uses promises rather than events.
But other than that,
it's the same as IndexedDB.
So anything you learn
using this library,
you can apply to using
IndexedDB directly.
In fact if you want to spoil
your day really early,
feel free to avoid the library and
write IndexedDB code directly.
But all the examples will
be using the library.
In the next chapter we'll take a look
at how you'd create a real life
index database in the browser.